easter is less than a day away and
community advocates
julie and jim danner want to make sure
everyone is fed for the holiday
we first met the danners back in
november when they held a thanksgiving
food drive for hundreds of families
now they're collecting hundreds of
easter dinners and around 1200 easter
baskets for those in need
it's been a tough year for so many and
the danners say they just want to take
away those worries for a little while
and people people need to have a special
day people need to have a normal day
people need to be able to celebrate
a holiday you know and not
not think about the struggle for a few
hours you know that's
that's it just let people have a little
bit of normalcy and a few extra smiles
for just one day we are down to the wire
but the dinners still need some help
they still need supplies for easter
baskets and fixings for tomorrow's
dinner
they're also looking for monetary
donations and delivery drivers
if you'd like to help we have more
information on our website
8newsnow.com